[Applause]
[Music] They are threatening
justice to protect their own conditions, rights, and security interests, but
we have
consistently expressed unconditional support for the Russian government and
will always be together on the anti-war, independent front in the future.
After doing so,
we reached a satisfactory consensus on how to protect conditional rights and security, invest in strengthening strategic cooperation and support alliances to bring about a solid peace from hell and beyond.  I am
confident that we will win a great victory in the battle of justice to punish the groups of babies who pursue ambition for hegemony and expansion and to create a stable development environment.